welcome to this video um it's a an
opponent from the UK to 4 11 rated Iran
powers Iran powers not sure what this
exactly is all about okay I plane the
neo Philidor and we get the Queen
tradeline what no you're not reading
okay let's see I've only playing this
sir um yeah playing this rally but they
also keep forgetting how exactly it is
played hmm ok so do I actually get the
chance to play King e7 like c6 c7 I
guess oh and i will take this chance
quite often you yes your bit
uncoordinated so you have difficulties
with that now I managed to get to e7 ok
so let's let's see if I go Bishop e6
takes King takes the snide g5 and I'm
losing instantly not good this Bishop f7
now
hmm bit tricky
okay maybe I know I know it looks like a
big time loss and it probably is but
getting the bishop is not to be sniffed
at and if it plays better up g5 i have f
six and possibly night age 63 routing
yeah okay i think this is a good one he
can take f 70 well this this i didn't
expect at all
I also don't think it is good really
okay let's let's take here so let's see
i was thinking Bishop c5 and this
threatens f6 what he's doing needs to be
like winning instantly other than that
it's its strategically terrible f6 does
not have seven this is obviously good so
let's let's let's do that though should
have seven Bishop b3 Bishop g5 is easy
and now i'm taking um this if I hanging
yeah okay this is what i meant with it
must be a very good in a very concrete
in a very concrete fashion and if i were
saying which I overlooked okay okay
let's do that it's not it's not the end
of the world because of the bishops
check
it's not it's not compensation but it it
means i can i can fight in this position
the real issue is the the bad King
position and the general bad development
I don't know i don't have my pieces and
play trying for 95 maybe it should play
five here nope and do it
now no 95 at the end this is a problem
on the aid hmm too bad maybe I can go to
g4 to you three the system yeah this is
okay
if i just take h2 is this too greedy
takes he can take everything and play
rook everyone at the end yeah it is too
greedy if you place
okay anyway I need to me to get get
developed check I didn't think about
that at all I just didn't think that
enjoy yeah well the sandwich it's a big
problem
rookie six just rook is six King f6
rupee six and I'm toast
check
hmm
yeah not much fun check yeah he just
invades with all pieces ah what deck
oh god i'm also down on 37 success
check yeah i was completely ignoring
that if i was heading check with this
this operation early in the game check
yeah after looks like 480 it was even a
mate who tried funny mate I just saw
work c5 winning yeah I overlooked simply
that e5 was hanging let's consider this
for a moment I it i think i really am i
did i did a bed check i played a bad
defense because i don't really think
that it should be such a disaster
because of the bishop pair and the
potential blockade on Dione only five I
mean why it is better of course but it
should be still a game but he played
this in a very direct fashion maybe
Knight f6 was really the big lemon night
f5 was very strong my problem was this
was my original intention but this just
looks so tell jack maybe this isn't a
problem yeah it isn't really
yes this for example is a position is a
playable position it's a not quite
compensation of course but it's playable
computer wants to do something like that
even this this this look at game isn't
isn't so easy because of the active King
I can I can defend at least continue the
game this is all very strong an idea
five just outright check very strong guy
is playing the optimum moves him
may is playing the the first line of the
computer for one hundred percent of the
time which is not saying is cheating you
mean a lot like so difficult but very
strong moves all the way rookie
follow-up check check let me quickly
check this you know the computer even
wants to play play 95 yeah I don't know
I'm not not saying anything here it's a
new account and on the other time
controls he's got crap ratings yeah I am
not sure if I'm if I should claim
something here it was very strongly
played at least him and hitting lots of
computer main moves okay thanks for
watching